you still got feelings for him
yeah that's honest I appreciate that
yeah what makes you stay you just feel
like you can't walk away
um
or do you do you think at some point
he'll change his mind
I think I did think that
I definitely think I was maybe living in
a bit of Hope
maybe there's like a bit of a carrot
being dangled in front of me you know
when I was realizing or when I was
questioning certain things
um
I think I'm probably in a better place
now because I'm quite aware of what the
situation is and I'm quite ready to just
kind of you know like move forward which
is great
um
I can't knock him completely because I
feel like there was a lot of things he
showed me you know how we're talking
about actions speak louder than words
um and I think some women will
ignore that because it's not what they
want to see it's not what they want to
feel you know they want to believe like
nah this guy's right for them but in
reality if someone is showing you
something yeah you've really got to take
that in so
um how old did you say you are 33 33. do
you ever worry like do you want a family
and like kids and stuff I've got a son
okay who's 14. okay
um I would want to have another child
however I do feel like I'm on a
short time frame now yeah well because I
would just think
um because I I've like broken up with
people or like ended things because I
don't want to waste time and because you
only have so much youth you know do you
ever worry you can't find someone else
because you're still emotionally
invested with this guy absolutely yeah I
feel like I've probably done that for
quite a while yeah so I definitely think
that um I call it blocking my blessings
yeah you know if you're emotionally
invested in someone else then you might
miss someone amazing because you're
mentally still there do you know what I
mean
um
yeah I think it's just I think women
generally speaking of it there's a lot
of us that do need to really take in
what's put in front of us so and this is
a common like complaint I hear from guys
because like they value you know Purity
and they value youth right and so like a
common complaint is okay you passed over
me in your 20s in your early 30s and now
you're expecting me to come in at 35 and
deal with all the damage that the
previous guys have done for the past
decade and it's it's funny because
everyone's like nodding they're like
yeah that happens yeah
so do you feel like that's for men an
unfair deal yes yeah I do wow that's
bigger you to say it's not fair because
I don't believe they should have to deal
with anyone's past trauma yeah that's
been caused by someone else I think it's
amazing if you do meet a man that wants
to be understanding to that level where
they want to try and fix that or help
you to heal but I definitely don't think
it's fair that women
put their past trauma on someone new
that they meet someone that comes into
their life that hasn't done nothing to
them they might that man might be
amazing it might be great you know but
because we've experienced
bad experiences and we've got that
trauma and that bit of scarring
we project that onto them that's because
you haven't healed yeah because
obviously you haven't taken that self
that time for yourself to focus and heal
and deal with over whatever your
problems were or your insecurities and
then you just hand it on to the next
person and obviously nobody's going to
handle that well so so what is healing
to you because I always hear this and I
don't I don't think you can like you if
they say the average person falls in
love three times in their lifetime yeah
so you only get so many chances at love
yeah and it's like I don't think anyone
fully heals no I think when I when I
refer to the term as healing I'm I'm
like take yourself back look at the
situation look at the mistakes you may
have made yourself look at the things
you allowed to happen that might have
hurt you
um and and vice versa what the things
that you may have done to that partner
in order for them to behave in a certain
way that you've them felt again was
targeted so I think when I say healing
I'm take yourself back take some time
out you know just focus on your health
focus on your mental well-being and do
whatever it takes whether it's
meditation whether it's a holiday
whether it's reading books like learning
a new skill that to me is healing so
when I've healed myself in the past I
haven't gone to a therapist on a
telephone that I don't know and I'm not
saying that that's not the right thing
to do although that it's the wrong thing
to do but for me I just took time out I
stopped dating I separated anyone from
my life that maybe I felt was putting me
in a predicament or making me behave or
act a certain way and just focused on me
and then eventually you come back to
yourself and so um a common complaint
that I hear from guys and it's funny
because as a girl like I know exactly
what you're saying but a lot of times
when guys hear this that sounds like
nonsense yeah and it's because there's
no tangible result yeah like there's
nothing that you can measure and say
that you did it's just like okay you
went on a vacation I don't know and you
thought about what you did wrong and
you're gonna do it better like how do
they know you're going to do it better
in the future yeah when I see something
like what what have you achieved after
that yeah like when I say a vacation I'm
talking six months somewhere I'm not
talking a holiday to Ibiza for seven
days with the girls and hey I'm over you
yeah like I'm talking like somewhere
where you really really take yourself
out of your current lifestyle your daily
routine and then you can evaluate and
obviously there is no time on healing
healing probably takes years never get
over everything but healing to a point
then you don't transfer it onto the next
relationship but I don't think you can
not transfer things to another you can't
no you if you take enough time I feel
like you can you can but there's always
going to be things that may trigger you
and it's up to you I don't I I genuinely
think that there's some things that your
partner might do that will prompt a
random response
you didn't even know that you had and
that's the moment you you take a step
back and you're like okay I haven't
dealt with this I'm going to revisit
that but also take the time and be
courteous enough to inform your partner
like Hey listen if you guys haven't had
that conversation this is what I dealt
with please bear with me it will not
happen again if you see it does let me
know feel comfortable to let me know so
I I really think that healing is
something that can take place also in a
relationship but you have had to have
done the bulk of the work for yourself
do you think that healing needs to have
therapy so there's some tangible result
because it's like if you're just talking
to your friends like they're more likely
to tell you what you want to hear where
a therapist will like sit you down and
tell you about yourself
and I'm currently doing therapy right
now and at first I was just like this is
like what white people do like no
literally because no no literally
this is this is literally my thought
process and even all the people around
me when I finally told them I'm gonna do
therapy they're like were you doing
therapy for that's like white people
stuff it completely changed my life like
completely the first thing I realized
was there's a lot of